so now we have a well-defined
computational problem that's going to
model
what the mass spectrometer is telling us
and here we'll study
a first idea of an algorithm for it so
first i'll tell you that the mass of the
entire peptide
is usually known so we'll usually
already know that
tyrosine b1 has mass 1322.
our algorithm is going to then say all
right let's generate
every possible peptide of that mass so
in this case for tyrosine b1 it's 1322.
form the spectrum of every one of those
peptides
and then let's look for matches with the
given spectrum
among those peptides this is an example
of a brute force algorithm
so in general a brute force algorithm is
going to try all possible solutions
that satisfy a certain condition
so then our question is to determine how
long this is going to take
we ask how many peptides have a given
integer mass so
in specific how many peptides have
integer mass equal to 1322.
here's a graph that shows the integer
mass of a peptide
versus the number of peptides that have
that mass
and if we look at 1322 i've shown red
lines here we go up from 1322
and then we go over and we see it's
almost at 10 to the 14th
so the answer is trillions of different
peptides have this mass
and that's not going to be good we don't
want to have to consider trillions of
different possibilities
so let's ask ourselves then what is it
that makes brute force so bad to begin
with
or at least this brute force algorithm
some brute force algorithms may work
well
if they choose the correct condition
here's a peptide nqel right that we
we're going to start working with
and another peptide tmdh
so the total mass of nqel is 484
and the total mass of tmdh is 484
but they're completely different right
they don't have any of the same amino
acids
and they're not going to have so by
extension they're not going to have any
of the same subpeptides
and so we need to find a way to exclude
this completely we don't want to
ever have to encounter this peptide all
right
and if the way that we're going to get
at that is to say
let's look at the spectra of these two
peptides so on the left here i've shown
the spectrum of tmdh
and on the right i've shown the spectrum
of nqel
they completely disagree right so you
may notice this they agree at zero
and they agree at 484. and nowhere in
between do they have the same two mat
two of the same masses so we want to use
this to our advantage we want to use
this to start designing an algorithm
that's going to eliminate tmdh based on
off of its spectrum which is
not good so our idea is
rather than try to form big peptides all
at once let's slowly build
up our candidate solutions from smaller
peptides
at each stage we're going to test its
spectrum and make sure it's
it's on the right track and if it's not
on the right track we're going to kick
it out
so that's going to allow us to restrict
the total number of peptides that are
under consideration